allison is with us in Orlando Florida
Allison how are you I'm good Dave how
are you better than I deserve what's up
well first of all worthy been all my
life learning all this stuff the hard
way kiddo
[Laughter]
baby step one good
just started I will be 50 years old at
the end of the month and I have just
basically squandered my life away
basically so once once I get to baby
step to where that snowball correct okay
do I go and pull my credit and because I
I have stuff all over the place like
credit cards I have student loans I have
medical whole I have and I haven't paid
on any of it because I've been a slacker
so do I pull my credit and go from there
oh you can or you can go back any
records that you do have I mean you
obviously have some knowledge that you
once had a student loan oh yeah well I
mean that part I know I mean I know my
student loan okay so you call them and
get updated information on the loan okay
and in any anybody that you do know me
if you had a MasterCard with so-and-so
you call so-and-so bank or credit union
and you go eh I'm moving out a slacker
Ville I'm gonna move into dilligent
Ville and we're gonna start working on
this so what's the starting point ready
set go and then if there's stuff you
just have no record of some of it may
show up on your credit bureau there's
not obligated to report it to the credit
bureau but okay you know what I would do
is start trying to make lists and and
how far back does all this stuff go
probably six seven years okay years nine
years maybe well you can probably comb
through your memory as you start writing
some of the stuff out and pull it out
any records that you do have your prob
gonna start to remember things and just
just write them down and go okay I did
have a medical bill over there it you
know West hospital or whatever it is and
make it you know write and just write it
down and go I don't remember what it is
but write it down and then at some point
you call them anybody that's not
bothering you today what I would do is
make two lists of debts old old bad
debts that you want to go clean up and
should go clean up the list number one
that's not bothering you list number two
is stuff you're paying on like if you
got a car payment already and you're
great and you know the student loans
they're you know these are things that
are a little more active and I'm gonna
make a list of those and I'm gonna have
to debts snowballs I'm gonna work the
actives off smallest to largest first
and then the inactive old ancient stuff
that we have to blow the cobwebs off of
second okay okay because most of those
you're going to call and settle them I
mean if you have a three thousand dollar
eight-year-old medical bill they'll
probably take five hundred bucks for
that oh yes and you get it in writing
and you want to settle it and move on
because you don't have a lot of money to
throw around at this I'm take it well
what's funny is them God certainly does
work in mysterious ways doesn't he he's
he's so good he and I just gave my
notice at one job and I am going to a
different job and I doubled my salary
phenomenal what do you make so I'm going
from from actually making about fifteen
thousand to making about forty thousand
so more than double my salary alright
well then you're able to move out of
slacker Ville that's good yes yes I am
so able to move out of slacker bill are
you really ready to do all this are you
gonna bear through you're gonna play
through if you are although I oh I am so
ready to do this I mean I'm gonna put
you through Financial Peace University
then it's a one-year membership every
dollar plus which connects to your bank
all the online stuff you can watch all
the lessons online and it includes the
course at your local church with the
membership kit I'm gonna give you a
one-year membership
hold on Kelly's gonna sign you up now
you play through kiddo this is time to
change your life
this is God telling you you got a chance
here now run with your chance this is
the Dave Ramsey show